[Musique]
au
total
tu sais que tu te voilà ça me manque
d'être alcoolos était beaucoup moins de
responsabilités these nos bébés mais
qu'est ce qui t'amène ici ce soir
ivresse sur la voie publique destruction
de biens personnels j'ai failli rendre
mon collègue aveugle la totale quoi
these se nourrit pin bonjour mère-poule
alors est ce que te parler de moi tout
ce temps oui mr tout tourne autour de
toi enfin c'était presque ça
je sors de désintox à oublier samantha
est parmi nous on va faire la pub est
comme quand on était chez les patriots
sahara
je voulais te le dire en face ma
meilleure amie épousé mon écran je veux
tout l'alcool du monde et je veux des
drogues et tout ça à la fois tu veux une
tasse de thé c'est pas du bluff c'est
tout ce que j'ai
pas que je ferai face à tout ça que je
ressentirai ses émotions ouais je sais
c'est la partie la plus difficile d'un
long chemin
pourquoi où c'était pas bien c'est ça et
intouchable tant que tu as passé un an
et un jour sabre et donc à qui je peux
me plaindre à personne
qu'est ce que je dois faire être une
personne normale de brosser les dents en
te la fais faire tourner tous les jours
c'est une métaphore où je dois vraiment
faire mon lit tous les jours c'est
bizarre je suis contente et à la fois un
peu triste
toi t'as pas toucher de balle comme
tu peux être fier mais elle me juge pas
quand je prends un verre de vin en
soirée c'est dur d'être un humain
j'entends ce que tu dis
[Musique]